the most comfortable men's boxers and
t-shirts you'll ever find are at leisure
of NYC their Ultra Soft bamboo boxers
feel as light as air and their silky
smooth supima cotton crewneck t-shirts
are amazing I love them you'll get 15
off with code Pacman at davidpackman.com
NYC Donald Trump will be arrested
tomorrow he will surrender in New York
City he will appear in court presumably
to enter a plea of not guilty at which
point he is expected to leave New York
City fly back to Florida and hold what
will certainly be an unhinged press
conference at Mar-A-Lago shortly after 8
PM eastern time we're going to be
covering all of it live we will be live
tomorrow with the arraignment and we
will be live tomorrow with the press
conference that is essentially all I can
tell you at this time because there are
so many unknowns at this coin one of
those unknowns is whether the
arraignment will be televised I'm going
to separate that question out just for a
moment because it's really its own
question and we will talk a little bit
about what is to be expected tomorrow
the latest news is that Trump will fly
from Florida to New York today Monday
and even though the arraignment is
scheduled for 2 15 tomorrow there are
reports that Trump will be at the
courthouse early in the morning why
isn't exactly clear certainly
fingerprints potentially a mug shot not
expected to be handcuffed based on
everything we know right now but that
doesn't take that long is it because of
security considerations well maybe
there's a numerous reports that New York
plans to close key streets for Trump's
arraignment Patricia Hurtado from
Bloomberg news reporting that and that
the entire area surrounding the
Manhattan courthouse is going to be
closed down to vehicle traffic it is
also known that there are
uh tunnels and different ways to get to
the main courthouse building from
surrounding buildings and for security
reasons presumably Donald Trump may be
brought in through some kind of
Securities path it's not exactly
completely clear we continue to learn
more about what are the charges
initially we didn't know then we knew
that the number was over 30. more
recently it's it's sort of uh focused in
on the number 34 questions about is it
all misdemeanors the latest report from
CBS news is that there are felony
charges here so not only charges against
Trump not only nearly three dozen
charges against Trump in this one of
three or four major criminal
investigations but felony charges as
well at least one of them CBS news
reporting former president Donald Trump
faces a felony charge A source told CBS
News Saturday
a person familiar with the matter said
to CBS News Trump is being charged with
falsifying business records in the first
degree which is a felony in New York
state now immediately the Law and Order
people coming out and saying it
shouldn't be a felony this is part of
the problem screw that well
if you're for Law and Order right now
that's a felony and if you are not above
the law if we have Justice then everyone
regardless of their position job wealth
or situation of power would be subject
to that law but how quickly the Law and
Order people change their tune when it
is all of a sudden inconvenient there
were concerns about violent protests as
a result of trumpists showing up here or
there now I don't believe we are yet out
of the woods because there is a protest
planned tomorrow at noon in New York
City involving repugnant and radical
reactionary Republican congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor green we will talk about
that separately but the good news so far
is that the protests we've seen at Trump
Tower in New York City and at Mar-A-Lago
have been pathetic
um a report from Bloomberg news is that
at Mar-A-Lago few show up to protest
Trump's indictment they there were a
dozen maybe two dozen people quite
pathetic and honestly I'm glad
I'm glad I don't want there to be
violence and there was some video from
New York City where I think there was
one pro tour one it's not even a protest
it's sort of like a show of support at
uh Trump Tower where there were one or
two people not one or two dozen one or
two people which is absolutely hilarious
now many of you have started to write to
me and said David you know we know
you're going to be away in a little bit
are you what's the timeline of this
Trump thing are you going to be around
to cover it the expectation
is that number one these things don't
move that quickly and number two you
always want to delay delay delay as much
as you can there's an interesting
article called Donald Trump's
time-tested legal strategy attack and
delay this article from dny u-z says
these two tactics have been at the
center of Donald Trump's favorite
strategy in court cases for much of his
adult life and will likely be the former
president's approach to fighting the
criminal charges now leveled against him
you want to delay as much as possible
and many attorneys will tell you there
are a whole bunch of reasons for this
you can delay with the hopes that those
in charge of Prosecuting the case get
frustrated change jobs whatever you can
delay and delay and delay with the hopes
that Witnesses forget their testimony or
they die or whatever the case may be it
is often said by attorneys in many
different areas of criminal law
the longer you can delay actually
adjudicating a case the better and so
none of listen the fact that I'll be
away next week shouldn't at all Impact
my ability to cover this because we
could be talking about months if not if
not years potentially here and that is
certainly to be expected I am not aware
in terms of the defense that this is all
political that this is all a Witch Hunt
that these are merely political
decisions rather than legal decisions
this is one of the main defenses we've
heard from people around Donald Trump I
can't think of anyone that has used the
demand of political investigations more
than Donald Trump when Trump and and his
political allies say investigate Hillary
lock up Hillary lock up Hunter charge
Joe Biden etc etc absent any reason to
do so it is they who have demanded the
political prosecution of their opponents
and Trump is at the top of that so every
time we hear this is all Alvin Bragg's
Soros politics this that the other thing
don't let your eye come away from the
ball
and the ball is all along Trump has been
at the top of the list of those who
demand the political prosecution of his
opponents let's now talk about the
potential gag order and the potential
for Donald Trump to be re-arrested
criminal defense lawyer wrote to me over
the weekend tears in his eyes I could
tell even though it was an email that
the guy was crying as he wrote to me and
he said David listen I'm a criminal
defense attorney where Trump can get
himself into real trouble here
is if he has a gag order placed on him
at tomorrow's arraignment
he may not be able to resist talking
about the case and that would be
considered a bond violation and it could
get Trump rearrested the latest news is
that a gag order is quote extremely
likely at tomorrow's arraignment
and Donald Trump has scheduled a press
conference for tomorrow evening okay so
this has this is a secondary story which
has the potential to completely explode
into a very different sort of situation
than this coordinated very dignified
arrest that is taking place tomorrow in
New York City Business Insider reports
let's go through it piece by piece a gag
order for Donald Trump is extremely
likely once he's before a judge legal
expert says Donald Trump can't seem to
stop talking about his indictment but he
may have to soon it's extremely likely
he'll be put under gag order one expert
said punishment in New York for criminal
contempt could be a one thousand dollar
fine or 30 days in jail such a gag order
would say to Trump and others involved
in the case do not speak publicly about
the case and yet an announcement from
yesterday that Donald Trump tomorrow
will be holding a press conference about
the arraignment in Marvel Lago the
announcement coming on Trump make
America great again 2024 letterhead
naturally and it says Tuesday April 4 8
15 Eastern that's tomorrow evening
president Donald J Trump 45th president
of the United States will deliver
remarks at Mar-A-Lago in Palm Beach
Florida at 8 15. this is expected to be
not only remarks but a press conference
if there is a gag order
and Donald Trump doesn't cancel that
event
and he speaks about the case against him
he would be subject to rearrest now I
know people are saying 30 days in jail
with trump it would probably be the
thousand dollar fine let's be completely
honest but it would make him subject to
rearrest and in all seriousness none of
them were crying when they emailed me
that I know of but numerous lawyers
wrote to me and said this is really
where Trump has to be careful the next
question mark which I believe is of
utter importance is whether this
arraignment will be televised
tomorrow's arrests surrender and
arraignment of Donald Trump
is of Paramount public interest this is
a former president of the United States
now indicted for crimes related to his
candidacy in 2016. he is being
prosecuted by the taxpayer-funded legal
system and is the epitome of a public
figure never mind just nationally but
globally the arraignment should be
televised but will it be we do not yet
know
it is imperative that there be cameras
in the courtroom tomorrow not only for
the reasons I just said but also because
of course Trump is going to lie about
what happens in this proceeding he will
say the judge was so unfair and the
prosecutors and everybody is just biased
and one of the only defenses we have
against those lies is to actually have
cameras showing what is going on the New
York Times Maggie Haberman appeared on
CNN and made the exact same argument
let's take a listen yeah what do you
think I mean if there is a camera in the
room that's a remarkable moment in and
of itself but it could be important to
actually get a clear view of what
happened in that side that courtroom
absolutely and there is a compelling
public interest argument to make it is
absolutely true that New York New York
is is really regressive in terms of
cameras in the courtroom I do expect
there'll be an argument made I'm not
sure what what the ruling will be on
that right but it's interesting I was
thinking as you were asking that
question now one of the things we saw
over and over both with Michael Cohen in
terms of trump and then other people in
the White House people have a habit of
taping Donald Trump and they have a
habit of taping Donald Trump because he
spends his own reality and will
contradict whatever people say about him
a camera would be pretty vital in terms
of people understanding what happened
and not being told that something that's
fake news and in an era where Trump is
saying that all of these reports are not
true I think there is a compelling
argument for it I am skeptical that it
will happen just I covered courts in
this state I know how against cameras in
the courtroom judges are here but I do
think there is going to be a compelling
argument made and even toggling to the
actual trial itself imagine right what
the public interest in that will be and
so will there be cameras allowed to
depict what occurs on the day-to-day
because I think certainly people would
want to announce right yeah I don't know
whether there will be cameras in the
courtroom tomorrow I sympathize with the
skepticism from Maggie Haberman because
indeed
oftentimes there's questions why weren't
there cameras in the courtroom and
sometimes it has to do with well it's a
federal court rather than a state court
and there are different procedures there
New York State also notoriously strict
about having cameras in the courtroom I
can't think of any legal issue any legal
proceeding where cameras in the
courtroom are more Justified than the
indictment of a former president of the
United States so by tomorrow we will
probably know more two live streams
tomorrow the arraignment in the
afternoon and the press conference at
Mar-A-Lago if it's not canceled based on
a potentially forthcoming gag order it
is going to be a crazy 24 36 hours I'm
glad to have you with us
one of our sponsors today is Leisure of
NYC offering Ultra comfortable fair
trade men's clothing at fair prices guys
know it can be very tough to find good
boxers and t-shirts the search is over
because all boxer briefs by Leisure of
NYC are made with amazingly soft
moisture wicking viscose from bamboo
super lightweight like air but it
doesn't Bunch up and it's also great for
the planet Leisure of NYC also makes
really great supima cotton crew neck
t-shirts less than one percent of men's
Basics today are made with supima cotton
it is the best out there it feels like
Silk quite frankly you can walk around
in a scratchy t-shirt all day or you can
enjoy the cloud soft feel of supima
cotton and actually love the shirt
you're wearing these are my go-to
t-shirts and boxers nothing else even
comes close to providing this level of
comfort and all of their products are
fair to trade and made sustainably go
pick up the most comfortable t-shirts
and boxers you will ever own but hurry
because they often sell out especially
the boxers go to davidpackman.com
NYC and you will get 15 off with the
code Pacman at checkout and the link is
down below
remember that the David packman show is
an audience supported program thank you
to the stunning number of new members
over the last week as we have dealt with
an angry right-wing mob coming after me
but they haven't succeeded and part of
the reason is thanks to you and the
folks who have signed up at
joinpakman.com keep it going my friends
you can use the coupon code indicted to
save on a membership at joinpakman.com
we all know who and what we're talking
about when we type that code in indicted
use it at joinpakman.com you'll get the
daily bonus show and so much more let's
take a look at the downward spiral of
the children of trump over the last few
days since we learned of the Trump
indictment we are not going to be
talking about Ivanka here Ivanka just
put out kind of a very short statement
on Instagram saying she's heard from
people all over the political Spectrum
concerned about what's going on very
very vague Ivanka does seem to be
wanting to stay far from politics after
the disaster of her first four years of
involvement in politics we then go to
Donald Trump Jr who now has a show on
Rumble and the downward spiral really
continues it's it's actually kind of
getting sad and listen I'm sure it is
very difficult for your father to be
indicted I'm sure it is also it's not
you know we know that Trump doesn't seem
necessarily to be the biggest fan of his
adult male children but that's another
story anyway here is Don Jr just
dissembling this is clearly an attempt
to intimidate a journalist and yet the
rest of Journalism the rest of the media
strangely silent
guys listen Maybe coincidences happen
but not anymore in 2023 I don't believe
watching literally anything for like the
last six years you shouldn't either the
fact that the IRS showed up at Matt
taibi's house on the same day that he
testified before Congress and their new
committee investigating the
weaponization of the federal government
is
a little bit beyond ironic
suspicious it's absolutely insane okay
that's how you beat opening statement on
the Twitter files Twitter Facebook
Google and other companies developed a
formal system for taking in moderation
requests from every corner of government
FBI DHS HHS DOD the global engagement
Center etc etc that's his opening line
and we think that it's a coincidence
that the IRS knocks on his door that day
all right so what this all has to do
with Donald Trump is unclear why
Junior's eyes are almost completely
swollen shut we don't know that seems to
be similar to his own dad and here is
Donald Trump Jr during his Rumble show
um really just furious about this entire
thing I was proven even more right than
I would have ever imagined because is
that even possible that nobody's been
more right than Don Jr about everything
I guess apparently you know Soros to
back Manhattan district attorney Alvin
Bragg okay and again I don't know why he
says sore roast backed but if he means
George sorospact we've looked at this in
detail remember George Soros funds
hundreds of programs one of the programs
George Soros funds is a pack that helps
to get DA's elected one of the DA's that
was helped buy that pack is Alvin Bragg
there has never been any contact between
Alvin Alvin Bragg and George Soros there
has never been any communication one way
or the other about a trump investigation
that's the connection that they're
talking about they want you to think
Soros is calling Alvin Bragg and saying
indict Trump is actually indicting my
father so let's be clear folks yeah this
is
like communist level this is stuff that
would make Mao
Stalin
uh Pol Pot it would make them blush it's
so flagrant it's so crazed when even
like the radical leftists of the
Washington Post are out there saying
it's not really based on facts it's not
really based on the Lots not really
based in reality but it's a hundred
percent based on politics when your
enemies are saying that
it's got to tell you everything you need
to know right now about where we are as
a country yeah where we are is it turns
out that the one-man crime spree that
was Donald Trump isn't above the law
just because he was President that's
what it tells us and that is a good
thing going now from Don Jr to Eric
Trump Eric Trump pulled one of these
tears in my eyes type stories he went on
Fox and Friends yesterday morning and he
says when news of the indictment broke
he was on a plane and that everyone in
the plane came up to him to hug him and
as always it's like do we believe these
stories guys Justice and and guys I have
to tell you people in this country
understand it I was on a plane I was on
a commercial flight when this whole
indictment broke people were coming up
to me giving me hugs the support is
unbelievable out there because people
understand that we've literally become a
Banana Republic we're now literally a
Banana Republic maybe he means
figuratively they've they've made a
mockery out of our our legal system in
this country yeah so I'm sure that that
happened and you know a lot of them were
really big strong guys some of them were
crying and they said to the flight
attendant bring this man more peanuts
because of how unfairly his family has
been treated and then next thing you
know the pilot came out of the cockpit
saluted Eric Trump and they all did the
Pledge of Allegiance and it was just an
incredible incredible day uh I don't
believe any of it obviously then uh
during the same appearance he tries to
say something about free speech and it
goes very very wrong
yeah
Rachel we're supposed to live in a free
country you're supposed to have a
freedom of speech right it's just the
number one thing that makes up our
constitution freedom is raised freedom
of expression yet you have conservatives
all over the country who are getting
de-platformed their businesses are
getting shut down who is that who is he
talking about Banks stop banking them
their their web service providers decide
to turn them turn them away it is true
that web hosts when they find out that
they're hosting extremist content
sometimes we'll say we're not hosting
this nonsense anymore that is true but
they want to pretend as though the
indictment of trump proving or improving
suggesting that even presidents aren't
above the law
is somehow an attack on everybody and as
a follow-up to the Eric Trump thing from
last week remember how last week I
played this clip for you where he
relates
CVS and Tylenol not Tylenol
Tylenol somehow to this indictment
remember this clip it is every single
day and this is a city I spent a lot of
time with you that is falling apart I
went into literally CVS the other day
and you can't buy Tylenol because it's
locked behind these glass counters
because there's so much theft and
there's so much looting or something
yeah so he wasn't able to get Tylenol at
CVS he then went on Newsmax and told a
totally different version of the story
where he says you actually it's it's
Advil you can't get it Dwayne Reed now
people in other parts of the country may
not know Dwayne Reed Duane Reade is like
a more local CVS it's it's similar and
they sell other things as well so wait a
second are you telling me that you first
went to CVS and they had no Tylenol
without a key and then you went to
Dwayne Reed and you couldn't get Advil
or was it just the entire thing was made
up in New York City homeliness is is
through the roof I went into Dwayne Reed
the other day did you and literally you
can't buy Advil and Dwayne Reed without
having somebody come up with a key and
unlock you know those little plastic
things that you pick up because there's
so much looting in the city I mean the
city is going to hell right now you look
nationally just about every every
Walgreens CVS Dwayne Reed they're all
locking up all of this stuff as I said
last week my hair product is regularly
locked up now I mean it's in very high
demand ever since I started using it but
um my girlfriend's uh deodorant is
locked up something I got from my baby
daughter was locked up I don't remember
what it was
might have been like baby Zyrtec was
locked up this has nothing to do with
not Prosecuting or Prosecuting Trump and
whether it's Tylenol or bilinol or
whatever it is I don't believe a word
this guy says but he is not doing well
clearly and I get it to some degree to
see my dad indicted and then begging for
money even though he's supposedly a
billionaire it would probably upset
upset me as well and that's what I want
to talk about next Donald Trump is a
billionaire I guess and he is begging
for money in a dark room with terrible
lighting looking as dark orange as we
have ever seen this guy
Donald Trump on the eve of his
arraignment and arrest and surrender and
fingerprinting and mugshot
recorded a video
in a very dark room where he is issuing
another plea for cash
he says he needs you to contribute now I
have to say it's not really clear what
you're contributing to are you
contributing to Trump's campaign are you
contributing to Trump's legal defense
fund what is he asking you for money for
doing the darkest we have seen Trump
literally and figuratively if you're
doing well because all of the things
that I've done have brought you wealth
and prosperity or at least you're
extremely comfortable it would be really
great if you could contribute to our
campaign you know how to do it ah so
it's a campaign contribution he wants no
president of the history of our country
has been subjected to such vicious and
disgusting attacks really but they only
attacked me because I fight for you it's
very simple they can't buy me and they
can't control me and that scares them
beyond belief doesn't really make sense
when you look at the polling but okay
since the very beginning I've shunned
the globalist special interest owners
who have made a fortune off of
destroying our country instead our
presidential campaign has always been
funded by Grassroots Patriots like you
your contribution today will show the
left that nothing can destroy the
greatest political movement in history
yeah so there are people donating to
Trump we we looked at some of that
fundraising data and indeed Trump raised
a pretty penny after the indictment was
announced but isn't he a billionaire
like why why does Trump need to raise
money why does a multi-billionaire need
people's money it doesn't really make
sense unless you understand that Trump
sees his followers as Marx in an ongoing
con now the fact that Trump is raising
money off of this
doesn't necessarily mean that it's good
or bad for Trump as I've said before it
does seem that Trump's followers are
being energized by the indictment and
indeed the indictment might help Trump
in the 2024 Republican primary I don't
see how the indictment gets Trump even a
single vote in a general election the
very same chaotic surroundings that
followed Trump everywhere which hurt him
in 2020
are going to hurt him in 2024 and an
indictment is absolutely chaotic now
Trump is trying to fundraise off of this
there's a good nice concise CNBC article
Trump campaign uses newly restored
Facebook page to fundraise off of the
indictment they have the official
election defense fund with a thousand
dollar match which of course we never
know if it's real or if it's not the
copy was as follows the radical left the
enemy of the hard-working men and women
of this country have indicted me in a
disgusting Witch Hunt please make a
contribution of 47 or more by 11 59 pm
to help defend our movement from the
never-ending witch hunts during these
dark times and we'll send you your very
own I stand with President Trump t-shirt
for free which as we know that could
become a collectible item uh I I wish
I'd stocked up on the Trump Knives By
the way before he was indicted I'm sure
they've just skyrocketed in value so
realistically
uh the grift simply continues this has
been a grift for a very long time and
it's not going to stop when the with the
indictment it wouldn't if Trump somehow
ended up in jail which is not going to
happen I think the grift would continue
from there and we are going to be
watching the next 48 hours very very
closely is there a gag order does the
fundraising continue do Trump's
protesters actually come out and seem
even remotely interested in defending
him or is it just a couple dozen people
at Mar-A-Lago all of it will be live on
our YouTube twitch and Facebook and it
is going to be quite a couple of days
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
let's talk about Marjorie Taylor green
on 60 Minutes dozens of you wrote to me
as many people wrote to me as the number
that protested for Trump at Mar-A-Lago
dozens dozens of you wrote to me and
said David what is your take about 60
Minutes interviewing Marjorie Taylor
green they are platforming a lunatic
they are pretending as though they're
normalizing the idea of Marjorie Taylor
green as someone who should be in
government it's just a matter of do we
agree about reviews rather than making
her out to be the dangerous extremist
who has no business in a position of
power I tweeted yesterday I understand
the concerns and I want to see the
interview first and the reason I said I
want to see the interview first is I've
long advocated for something called
responsible platforming and by
responsible platforming I mean
it's not about who you interview
it's how you interview them and so for
example when I have someone on the show
who is explaining uh nuclear fission to
us as a subject matter expert I handle
that interview differently than when I
interviewed interviewed for example a
white nationalist Neo-Nazi Richard
Spencer if I'm an average of Spencer on
I need to be prepared to make sure that
my audience understands his extremist
ideas are dangerous that they're bogus
and so on and so forth I think people
get this the point is the interview's
appropriateness is evaluated based on
how the interview is handled and it
wasn't handled the best by Leslie Stahl
but it wasn't the end of the world
overall I don't like that I think the
interview did normalize Marjorie Taylor
green to a degree
that's where I come down it wasn't it
wasn't overall a a softball interview
but there were moments that weren't so
good let's look at just a couple of
moments here's one question about
whether Marjorie Taylor green has
deliberately styled herself after Donald
Trump how much have you styled yourself
and why don't we have audio here
I'm not sure who is ah we do have audio
my headphone has become unplugged let me
plug that back in beautiful all right
let's take it from the top how much have
you styled yourself after Donald Trump
hmm people say and by the way this look
from Marjorie Taylor green one thing I
want to say and I won't harp on it is
Green's attitude the entire interview
was sort of of like this isn't a serious
show Leslie Stahl isn't serious and I'm
above this this is just me placating the
fake news and it was pretty disgusting
but let's not harp on that that you are
Trump in high heels I didn't
intentionally sound myself after
president Trump but I can see how people
draw those similarities so we both come
from the same industry construction
um I also have pretty much a plain
speaking style yeah and and so does he
okay so a little bit fluffy a little bit
fluffy one of the better moments was
when Leslie Stahl was prepared with fact
checks and tweets and everything to
question Marjorie Taylor green about
things she had previously said including
that the Parkland shooting was a false
flag and other things Marjorie Taylor
green basically just denies it but I do
think this was one of the stronger parts
of the interview let's take a look
shortly after she arrived in Washington
the democratic-led house
ousted her from her committees because
of her past endorsement of violence
against some democratic leaders and her
history of embracing Q Anon that she
explained in a speech on the house floor
I stumbled across something and this is
at the end of 2017 called Q Anon I was
allowed to believe things that weren't
true and that is absolutely what I
regret well I apologize to my colleagues
I think apologies are important
okay did you ever apologize to Nancy
Pelosi
about the bullet to her head I didn't
say that so I don't need to apologize
what words don't you like it other
people also ran my social media so now
it's like listen person the party of
personal responsibility that was other
people well if other people liked
something about Nancy Pelosi needs a
bullet to the head and you don't agree
with it shouldn't you loudly denounce
the sentiment oh no other people run my
social media I don't think I did that
are you saying that you don't stand by
what's on your social media well of
course I stand for what's on my social
media but at times not you're not always
in control we have all kinds of people
that work on Art so it's not your fault
oh okay got it well great responsibility
huh special media did you apologize for
your position on Parkland Florida what
was my position on Parkland Florida that
it was a false I don't know if you
actually have my position no I never
said Parkland was a false did you okay
so there's a post it's called the payoff
to keep his mouth shut since it was a
false flag plan shooting to which
Marjorie Taylor green responded exactly
hmm oh I've never said that school
shootings are horrible I don't think
it's anything to joke about we fact
checked before I got to this interview
have you fact checked all my statements
from kindergarten through 12th grade
okay that's called the red herring not
not at issue she's denying having said
things that are on the record in college
and as I've paid my taxes and never
broken a law and the only I got a few
speeding tickets do we need to remember
it doesn't have anything to do with
breaking the law it's she's denying
having said things that she said this is
how you try to distract talk about those
two because I think where you're going
down is the same attacks that people
have attacked me with over and over and
over she means holding me accountable
for things I've said well if this is
what you're known for I think it's good
that you're responding to the charges I
think I think I think it's a legitimate
because people for us to constantly
focus on it but never focus on anything
good about me there is nothing good
that's the pro I mean this it's a sad
thing but she's done nothing good since
coming to Congress she's only had this
path of Destruction where she harasses
the victims of school shootings spreads
conspiracy theories spreads medical
disinformation and then she's never held
accountable for it so this is an attempt
to ask her about the things she's done
which are basically saying horrible
things
they button this up and we'll move on
you want to bring the Republican Party
closer to your views you want to bring
the country closer to your views you've
said that okay I here are some of the
things you've said
um that America should have a Christian
government that abortion should be
banned nationally that you want to
defund the FBI
yes
you want immigration to stop for four
years you've said those things correct
oh yeah these are these are some of my
views the Constitution the very first
amendment prohibits having a religion in
the government
yet the founding fathers quoted the
Bible constantly and were driven by
their faith
that's a total cop-out by the way
there's a fervent supporter of the now
indicted Donald Trump
she was a featured speaker at his rally
in Waco last weekend while she's adored
here the latest National poll has her
approval rating at just 29
Marjorie telegrin you happen to be here
foreign
would you like to run for the Senate and
I will fight like hell for you I thought
the question for her and the country is
can she expand her Brash MTG brand
beyond the right-wing populist base I
believe the answer is obviously not so
listen some fact checking there are
certainly Marjorie Taylor green is a
narcissist much like Trump and so you
never really get her because no matter
how you push her eventually she'll say
she's being misquoted or you don't
understand or she's actually correct or
whatever the case may be one other
moment I do want to show you from this
interview and I would I would watch the
whole thing if you you know really want
to understand the full scope of it she
said actually the government the US
government really isn't worthy of much
respect and deserves to be attacked but
also he's often an attack mode
and you appear to be
yet I think but I think our government
deserves it they don't really deserve to
be respected that much right and of
course the government that doesn't
deserve much respect and deserves to be
attacked is the one that she works in
and makes 175 000 a year for doing and
is paid through the taxpayer uh funded
salaries of everyone that is in her
position but it's a it's an entity that
should be attacked
so overall this interview was an
atrocity it was more an atrocity because
of the things that Marjorie Taylor green
said I don't think that there's some of
you came away from this saying this was
a total puff piece and it's horrible
what Leslie Stahl did
others came away saying it's amazing how
Marjorie Taylor green was held
accountable by by Leslie Stahl I think
that there were some really good
attempts to hold her accountable she's
really slippery like Trump is slippery
and her base is not going to think twice
about supporting her based on this
interview we all understand it for what
it is so I don't know that damage was
done but I don't know let me put it this
way I don't know that damage was done to
Marjorie Taylor Green's reputation and I
don't know that the interview was too
damaging to 60 Minutes my preference
would have been
not to have her on there at all after
seeing this interview I want to hear
from you let me know what you think
another player is entering the 2024
Republican primary it's former Arkansas
governor ASA Hutchinson who will be
running against Donald Trump
Nikki Haley and vivec ramaswamy he
announced this when speaking to Jonathan
Carl from ABC not exactly making huge
headlines understandably but let's take
a listen when I spoke to you earlier
this year you said you were thinking
about running for president have you
made a decision are you running I have
made a decision and my decision is I'm
going to run for president of the United
States wow while the formal announcement
will be later in April in Bentonville uh
I wanted to make that'll be a real party
clear that to you Jonathan I am going to
be running and the reason as I've
traveled the country for six months I
hear people talk about the leadership of
our country and I'm convinced that
people want leaders that appeal to the
best of America and not simply appeal to
our worst instincts I always find it
funny when they say they've traveled the
country and I know it's sort of like you
have to do it and you have to say it but
do you really need to travel the country
to figure out a lot of these things it's
always is a weird thing to hear and that
inspires me when I see everyday
Americans just saying give us good
leadership give us Common Sense
consistent conservatism and optimism
about our great country yeah and that
inspires me and I believe I can be that
kind of leader for the people of America
all right so he has absolutely no shot
but it is interesting to see more people
enter uh if I were a betting man and I'm
not my guess is Asa Hutchinson doesn't
even make it past the first Republican
primary now that being said more
candidates generally does seem to be
better for Donald Trump the more people
there are running the Republican primary
what we see in the polling is that it
helps Trump versus DeSantis we have some
new-ish polls I'm trying to look at ones
that are actually sort of like well well
rated there's a Trafalgar group poll
which is a right-leaning poll it's a
multi-way poll it has Trump over
DeSantis by 34 with Liz Cheney who
doesn't seem to have any plan to run at
10 percent
uh then we have an Insider Advantage
poll that's a B rated poll Trump over
DeSantis by 33 and then we have a B plus
rated yugov poll in this poll Trump does
better with more candidates this isn't
surprising this is what we've seen when
it is just Trump versus DeSantis Trump
leads by 26 and when it is Trump versus
a whole bunch of people Trump leads by
31 and we could go further but this is
sort of where we are right now so
interesting uh that ASA Hutchinson is
running I truly wonder you know when
when people like this run
are they sitting in a room where someone
is telling them you've got a shot at
winning because they obviously don't or
is it that they're sitting in a room and
advisors say you don't have a shot but
this might raise your public profile you
might get yourself on a debate stage and
then you can parlay that into being a
contributor to Fox News or something
like what is actually in their minds
when they decide to run what do they
think versus what is the reality of what
can come from it and what is the basis
on which they're making these these
decisions it's an interesting thing we
now have a four-way race in the
Republican primary with one of those
four candidates under indictment and
we're going to very closely follow the
direction that this goes
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show anytime
there is a massive news story as
Monumental as the arrest of a former
president of the United States you have
your main story and then you have sort
of subsidiary stories and then you have
secondarily subsidiary stories one of
those secondarily subsidiary stories
that has caught the eye and ear of many
of you is what is going on with attorney
Alan dershowitz and Trump's former
personal attorney Michael Cohen now to
give you the background on this Michael
Cohen friend of the show good guy he
used to be Trump's fixer he was directly
involved in the Stormy Daniels hush
money payments he served prison time for
his involvement in those crimes which
now Trump is is being indicted for and
Alan dershowitz is a historically
left-wing lawyer who has really started
to become a darling of the right
regularly appearing on Fox News and
Newsmax and Steve bannon's show as a
defender of trump legally and dershowitz
is always quick to say listen I voted
against Trump and I look forward to
voting against him again but this is so
unfair and that's so unfair and he's
being treated so unfairly the new thing
and this is this is just fit
unbelievable stuff
dershowitz says he's going to sue
Michael Cohen okay this started last
week with dershowitz on Fox News I'm
going to take you through the entire
story dershowitz on Fox news said
Michael Cohen tweeted that I was
involved with underage girls on Jeffrey
Epstein's Island and now Michael Cohen's
going to be in trouble so this is the
start of the story here's dershowitz on
Fox shooting together two inapplicable
statutes and using Michael Cohn let me
tell you something about Michael Kong
he's not through with his problems he
just tweeted about me saying because I
had attacked his credibility that I was
involved with underage girls on
Epstein's Island I'm about to sue him
now for defamation as you know the woman
who falsely accused me acknowledged that
she may have made a mistake in
misidentifying me and I would normally
not sue somebody for I'm just going to
sue usually I wouldn't but I'm gonna Sue
writing that kind of nonsense but this
is Michael Cohn
to try to
Donald Trump from running for president
of the United States single-handedly
for defamation not let him get away with
that and when I sue him I will be able
to prove his repeated lies because he
can't refuse to testify in a civil case
so his problems are just beginning I'm
going to make it a little easier for Joe
Jackson to tattoo to uh did he say Joe
jackapina
well as I've said before any first year
up and if it wasn't in Manhattan this
case has to get out of Manhattan all
right so there is dershowitz saying he
will be suing Michael Cohen then he
appears on Alex Jones Show and again
when we talk about the downfall of Alan
dershowitz in a Time past
dershowitz would never even consider
appearing on the program of someone like
propagandist Alex Jones it would just be
out what no of course I'm not appearing
on Alex Jones Show but here is
dershowitz almost pretending like it's a
normal show saying he is indeed suing
Michael Cohen Rob start over you're
gonna assume Michael Cohen that's that's
big news please tell us
your defamation and then the question
that if he takes the witness stand he'll
be asked you say you started telling the
truth but you just lied about Alan
dershowitz you know he wasn't on Epstein
sound you know he's never had sex with
an underage girl he's just got mad at
him because he called you a liar so you
made up a story about him so you're
still lying right I wasn't going to get
around that yeah so durso it's very soon
will be really inconveniencing Michael
Cohen I guess and then again later
continuing to follow the threat of this
story dershowitz finishing the rounds by
appearing on Steve bannon's program on
real America's voice and he says you
know after I threatened to sue Michael
Cohen Michael Cohen texted me and said
I'll take the Tweet down but their show
it's doesn't care he's still going to
sue if he apologized or took it down or
would you back off that are you gonna go
after him hard on this well let me read
you the email he just sent to me Alan as
you know from our conversation on my
podcast I have and has always had had
tremendous respect and admiration for
you as a constitutional lawyer and
Scholar if you were angered at my tweet
why not just have called me and express
that to me I am happy to remove the
tweet I am happy to remove the Tweet but
similarly I ask that you treat me with
the same respect that I treat you feel
free to call me at any time well he's
willing to remove the Tweet that's not
enough you know when when you throw a
skunk into the Jury Room you can take
the skunk out but the smell Still
Remains he accused me of associating
with a pedophile on an island with young
people it's just a total and complete
and categorical line well now see now
I'm confused I my understanding was that
dershowitz was saying is it's true he
did associate with Epstein but he said
simply never did anything specific
involving underage girls now in any case
my prediction other than Alan dershowitz
never recovers his reputation my
prediction is that Alan dershowitz
doesn't Sue because if he were to sue
Michael Cohen for defamation whatever
the outcome would be dershowitz would be
subject to Discovery and examination and
even if it's true that dershowitz was
never involved with young whatever you
I don't think Alan dershowitz at this
point wants to have to answer questions
under oath about his relationship with
Jeffrey Epstein so call me crazy I don't
expect dershowitz to Sue I could be
wrong I'm terrible at predictions we
will follow it and we will see
ladies and gentlemen my April Fool's
joke was an overwhelming success and
also backfired very very badly on
Saturday April 1st I put out a video
called I'm leaving YouTube The Mob one
the show is over that video as of this
recording has more than half a million
views
overwhelmingly people understood that
it's a joke and part of the reason you
could tell it was a joke is in the video
I say that the right wing mob took
everything that our toilets aren't even
flushing at the studio and that I'm
having to flush 10 to 15 times now
that's a reference to Trump's obsession
with toilets the entire thing was a joke
but one of the things that is a re this
is sort of a math thing okay and I I
realize this
if 500 000 people see the video
and 99.9 realize it's a joke
if 0.1 percent don't realize it's a joke
that's still 500 people who think I'm
being serious and of those 500 people
half might email me now I think in
reality the numbers are more like
99.5 of the audience realized it was a
joke but about half of one percent
didn't
when these are the numbers that's
thousands of people
and I received hundreds of emails saying
David I'm so sorry
that this is happening I can't believe
it uh Brian Tyler Cohen fellow YouTuber
texted me and said hey people are
contacting me saying you've got to help
David packman he needs help they're
taking his show can you get them a
lawyer can you help him I heard from
actors and politicians that I didn't
even know had any idea who I was saying
David I'm really upset can I can I get
you an agent can I get you how can I
help you get the show back and I
explained to everybody it's just an
April Fool's joke but it is really
something else a couple of the messages
that I got
um here is one this this I really found
this one funny Jill commented my husband
called out to me while I was in another
room Pacman is ending the show The
anti-woke Mob one and I called back
today is April 1st
I love this uh I I'm visualizing Jill's
husband yelling from the other room and
Jill immediately knows what's going on
and says it's April 1st and then Jill's
husband goes oh and then goes right back
to it but Jill did say I would have
believed it if I saw the video first I
got a bunch of different voicemails
about this here's one
hello David please stick with it don't
let them son of a
put you out of business you're stronger
than they are
I don't think they got God on their side
when it gets down to it just keep up the
good fight and help us out yep well
listen we're okay we're okay I did get a
second voice I actually got hundreds of
voicemails about this I just picked two
I'm from Minnesota I just want to tell
you that we're with you man we're this
is awful what's happening and I'd like
to see you get back on anyway if there's
anything I can do to help let us let us
know so listen
um
I appreciate the outpouring of support
after the right wing mob did come after
me we are not canceled in fact March on
YouTube was one of our best months in a
long time thanks to the right wing mob
they generated such interest in what we
are doing and of course the bad faith
takes about what we did led to a
backlash where we actually uh I I'm so
grateful to everybody is the point
um one other aspect to this which I have
to say has been so uplifting some people
wrote to me and said David you know I
realized it was an April Fool's joke by
the end of the video but in the first 40
50 seconds I thought it was for real and
I was so upset that it made me realize
how much I value what you do I was
taking it for granted and then when you
said that they won that they canceled
you I became so upset that I realized I
really should actually be supporting the
show if I was this upset at the prospect
of the show being canceled it made me
realize I actually really value this and
I should I should get a membership for a
couple of bucks and a couple dozen
people wrote to me about that so listen
if you were upset by the joke it's just
a joke okay that's all it is the show is
here we had a fantastic March we are
here we've got so much going on we're
pushing into the primaries the Trump
indictment the arraignment all of it the
2024 election and I appreciate every
single person in the audience including
everybody who has started new Support
over the last week let's keep going
let's press forward
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P there is a very
wealthy caller who doesn't like what I
do and is going to try to get me removed
from YouTube listen to this
hey punk ass kid hey I'm gonna call
YouTube and tell them I'm gonna back out
my support for them if they don't take
down every post on YouTube that you've
made whoa so don't be surprised Monday
if there ain't none of yours left on
YouTube whoa I'm a very wealthy man I
pay a lot of money to YouTube you little
broke piece of waste of sperm wow wow
well we are going to look into that very
very strongly and uh I do hope and pray
that by the time you hear that voicemail
all of our videos haven't been removed
from YouTube alright so we'll look into
that very strongly we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today we are now
learning about the judge who is going to
handle Donald Trump's arraignment
tomorrow the judge is considered
no-nonsense
we are going to talk about that number
two
the Twitter blue check marks for
verified individuals rather than people
who just are signing up for Twitter blue
what is happening there is Major drama
involving the New York Times
it's crazy what is going on with Twitter
uh verification and it's the continued
decline of Twitter which we will discuss
and lastly Brittany Greiner is calling
for the release of an American reporter
detained in Russia much like she
previously was it is all escalating it
is all building and we are talking about
all of it on the bonus show oh the bonus
show
now not only with an anti-endorsement
from Alex Jones but with an
anti-endorsement from Candace Owens
David Pacman does not have a soul he
doesn't have a soul okay if that
anti-endorsement makes you curious about
the bonus show then by all means sign up
at joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code indicted but you have to spell it
correctly Trump spelled it indicated
when he posted about being indicted that
won't work as a coupon code but the
correctly spelled indicted will save you
big bucks at joinpakman.com I will see
you on the bonus show and then on
tomorrow's show then on the Trump
arraignment live stream and then on the
Trump press conference live stream much
going on in the next 36 hours
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors the most
comfortable men's boxers and t-shirts
you'll ever find are at leisure of NYC
their Ultra Soft bamboo boxers feel as
light as air and their silky smooth
supima cotton crewneck t-shirts are
amazing I love them you'll get 15 off
with code Pacman at davidpackman.com NYC